all ego Ethan Paige my man uh aw is
having his very first show in Canada
some would say long overdue I would be
one of those people to say long overdue
how excited are you to bring the product
home oh my gosh
for so many reasons obviously because
aew is the best professional wrestling
in the world and Canada professional
wrestling is
almost part of the culture it's almost
part of the tradition for me at least
like a growing up in Hamilton Ontario
it's a part of the history of wrestling
and Toronto is a huge wrestling City so
for aew to bring their style and brand
and their fandom across all of Canada is
huge I know there's fans have been
tagging me in a million things telling
me that they're flying from different
provinces to come to Toronto to watch
these shows so it's huge and it's long
overdue and what we do for professional
wrestling is completely different than
any other company in the world it's an
atmosphere unlike any other so I can't
wait for Canada to experience it
yeah it's true we are it's part of the
culture we don't say hello in a way we
close on each other when we say hi
that's how we do it
yeah I didn't if I just lie on the
stream like what's up I just ran just
like could you forearm
I was telling some some uh big wrestling
fan friends of mine that are from the US
about the show here
uh and I was like I was saying to them I
was like I think everybody in the city
is going to be here and they're like
what do you mean by everyone to say like
like media but I'm like no I think
everybody in the city is just so excited
that you know aw's finally coming here
that they're going to be here are you
going to have a lot of people do you
know a ton of people that are already
going to be at the show like do the
family friends oh yeah yeah oh yeah so
uh the closest thing I've been able to
do was in Detroit so I had my daughter
and my wife there but this is like as
close to home as humanly possible unless
we ran an event in cops Coliseum for
some reason this is this is
this is a poor phrase to say but this is
as good as it gets for me so to get my
family
to get my family into like an event like
this for a venue like this uh and I I
can only imagine Ethan page will be
doing something revolving around the
fact that I am the greatest Canadian
athlete of all time but uh it's it's
it's it's truly special so I'm gonna
make sure to have everybody that I love
that supported me from the start because
it took me many many years to get to
this level of my career to just be there
to kind of enjoy it with me
do you have a moment that you remember
from like when you were a young
wrestling fan where you were close to
home or somewhere in Canada and like you
saw a show and you just went this is it
like this this is the rest of my life
honestly there's there's a couple
moments like that I don't know exactly
where the show was but my grandfather
and my father took me to uh an old
wrestling show and I saw like the
Undertaker walk out I saw Macho Man live
and that stuck with me forever uh and
then once I got really into the fandom
of professional wrestling I went to Ring
of Honor shows in Toronto just as a fan
and then once I started wrestling trying
to get on the pre-show and ring them on
or to wrestle in the big city of Toronto
so like there's there's definitely
levels to having these moments of oh
this is what I should be doing and I
hope I get that same kind of feeling
walking down the ramp in Toronto uh just
because yeah this is a dream come true
like I've wrestled in huge venues All
Over America uh in countries all over
the world but to be able to come back to
Canada as a quote unquote success story
is the greatest accomplishment
career-wise so far
yeah let's talk about aew uh as a brand
as a company as a style for a second
because uh people that aren't let's say
uh Die Hard wrestling fans are hearing
about aw what's this what is it about
um where you work where you wrestle that
is so unique that is drawing people in
right now well there's I would say it's
it's to two two reasons one is the fan
base and the atmosphere that the fan
base creates it you don't have to like
professional wrestling to enjoy all
elite wrestling I promise you uh any
previous thoughts you had about
wrestling throw them out the window just
get a ticket go with your one friend
that's been telling you to go to
wrestling shows and just say you know
what this is the time I'm gonna say yes
I'm gonna go to aew because it it's it's
a vibe there is this Synergy with the
performers and the crowd everybody is
there to put on a show together even the
fans and I would say the second thing
that makes us different than everybody
else is
how much freedom and creativity the
performers get and how much
um how much of ourselves we're allowed
to put into the characters and the show
so I have almost full control over all
legal Ethan page so you're getting what
I feel is the best version of myself and
every performer on the show is ready to
live or die on their same thing their
performance and who they are and what
they're willing to give so everybody's
given 110 it's like nothing else you
gotta go
yeah man 100 what is what is your
um like I know that there's a bunch of
belts in the company I know there's a
bunch of different ways to get a
championship there but for you for all
ego Ethan Paige yeah what are you gonna
what are you getting what are we gonna
get from you like what's the top for you
oh oh the top oh geez probably movie
star leaving wrestling and becoming like
the rock but for right now I would say
the all Atlantic Championship is what I
have my sights on uh the current
champion is pack I know I have to uh
rise up the ranks but for me the
Canadian flag is on the title literally
it's on the Belt I need to win the belt
I need to become the all-inning champion
to become the king of the Atlantic and
uh yeah conquer the world so that's my
first step after that world championship
gold is obviously in my sights but I'm
not trying to skip ahead or jump the
line
we know you got a million dollars now
this pack ever smiled I've never seen it
I've never I've never seen it not as
good as eat the page that's for sure
is there anyone on the roster who you're
excited to show like your hometown to
and your hometown crowd to who is like
has has never maybe doesn't have a lot
of experience in Toronto or in Canada
you're like oh I gotta take you out like
let's go
uh Dante Martin
okay yeah yeah I uh Dante Martin and uh
the acclaimed I think those guys are
awesome and honestly you know what I
love the guns
the guns in the firm and the three of us
have uh natural chemistry that I didn't
even know was possible maybe it's
because their dad is my fourth favorite
wrestler of all time so that gives them
a little Edge to become friends with
either page but uh yeah I I would love
to hang out with the guns in Toronto and
for honestly for the Toronto fans to get
to see them perform because their energy
is like nothing else especially Austin
he's off the wall
so who is on your Mount Rushmore
yeah so so you know top four so top four
literally the fourth favorite is Billy
Gunn it's a it's a running joke but also
the truth my number one is the rock uh
my number two is the Macho Man Randy
Savage my number three is Razor Ramon
and my number four is Billy Gunn
easy you did you did not even stutter
you didn't even think twice about that
you know that list oh yeah because I
know who I've been mimicking and ripping
off my whole career so
[Laughter]
have you had a chance to because I know
he's going to be in town actually The
Rock's gonna be in town the same week
that you guys are uh you guys are there
you're gonna yeah is there anything
gonna happen listen if if the people's
eyebrow wants to hang out with the best
smile in professional wrestling I'm I'm
game I'll hang out with Black Adam too
he could pick
[Applause]
and now I know you're a collector
um you're out there that's your that's
your Vibe when you're not you know
by slamming people in the ring what's
your what's your number one Holy Grail
item that you have that you've found in
all of your toy collecting oh that I've
found so it was actually gifted to me by
Hornswoggle uh for Christmas many years
ago it's the combat belt Batman it's the
first Batman animated series figure that
came out uh it's the one they featured
in all the commercials and it's the
rarest one of them all I have it like
still on card in the box and like for me
the Nostalgia of the toys is what I love
the most and chasing the feeling I had
when I was a kid and how special these
things were for me so to have that toy
fully packaged to look exactly like it
did when it came out that's huge for me
that's awesome finally man you know for
fans I know
the saying is thrown around a lot right
now
it's the best time to be a wrestling fan
right the boys time like there's there's
so much to see uh so much to enjoy
pretty much every day of the week
um is that a feeling that you yourself
share that's the best of you wrestling
fan and it's the best time to be a
wrestler also oh it's the uh best time
to be a wrestling fan for sure just
because not only are the companies
providing all these amazing shows for
you guys but the talent is also creating
their own content and their own shows
and kind of giving you another Outlook
uh outside of just the wrestling show so
content wise and trying to actually
enjoy these performers you could
literally do it not on a daily basis
almost an hourly basis it's so crazy
right now so yeah it's awesome
and for you do you think this is the
best time to be a performer in the ring
yeah so I want to say yes but this is
all I know and I know people said that
back you know Attitude Era was insane
and uh I hear a lot of the the guys talk
about what the crowds were like back
then and a lot of them actually related
to the crowds at aew and the crowds
right now like we go to some of these
towns and when I was going out there
with Scorpio sky and Dan Lambert I
genuinely could not hear not only myself
speak but Dan's standing right next to
me or Sky standing right next to me it's
an atmosphere like I I'll say it 100
times the atmosphere is like nothing
else and if you strip it down to just
that alone you're going to want to be in
the building to see it and I'm lucky
enough to be one of the performers
literally in the center of it all
that's awesome man hey thanks for taking
the time uh can't wait to see you next
week yeah thanks Carlos cheers buddy